um i said where are the prosecutors
working hard to indict your dumb ass uh
a very emotional eric trump almost cries
on hannity let's listen to this [ __ ]
chucklehead
if hunter's last name was trump that's
all anybody would talk about
that's a big problem for this country
moving forward if we have a two-tiered
justice system sure
and sean where are the prosecutors right
now you know the same prosecutors
they'll go after my father every single
day for nothing right just because they
want to disqualify him because he's
clearly the frontrunner for 2024
right where are those prosecuted hillary
rodham clinton is a new york resident
let me just kind of you know break that
down for you she lives in chappaqua new
york and guess where trump tower is
located it's located on fifth avenue
in new york where are these prospects
all sorts of offenses
where's leticia james in this whole
thing is she just gonna ignore this
because
hillary happens to be in her political
party
we don't get this fixed
what's funny is the john durham thing is
a federal case wait a second wait a
second wait a second here i think i
think we have a guest here might be
coming in uh to respond to this video um
can can you hear me over there
yes i can
you ca
uh sir you is this eric trump are you
eric trump are you here to respond
yes i don't like the way that everyone
is talking about me and my father
leticia james is coming after my family
because it's unfair
it's unfair
you know you committed crimes it seems
what
what do you
no
no
[Music]
so so you're saying so you're saying
that your accounting firm dropping your
father's business
um
does your does your dad know who you are
by the way
what does he know who you are eric this
is is your dad taking your phone calls
uh
have you heard from my dad no i i have
not heard from him i mean it's been a
couple weeks he was on the show a couple
weeks ago but
but um eric
what what's wrong eric are you all right
why why are you so upset are you upset
because you think you're going to go to
prison are you going to be someone's
[ __ ]
eric eric get it together eric you're on
live you're on live this is not recorded
you're on live get it get it together
get it together here get it together
we're live right now we're we're live
we're live
on youtube twitter and twitch uh the
tony
why is leticia james coming after us
you committed crimes in the state of new
york it appears not only criminal but
civil as well i think they're gonna i
think they're gonna i think they're
gonna cut down who is it is that worse
yeah way worse
now
also also
also if the federal government figures
out what you did with fraud did you guys
commit fraud did you commit fraud
what
are you are did you commit fraud your
business commit fraud i i don't you know
what fraud means you know what
broadcasting people coffee here
you what i just give people coffee you
get people at
at the trump organization you're just
the coffee boy
they just say go make some copies and
go get some coffee
what are you making copies of do you
shred anything at the trump organization
is there a shredder there or do you just
use the toilet
are you talking about the confetti room
the confetti there's a confetti room
yeah sometimes they say we're gonna have
a party until then they're like go shred
this to this to make him
they go shred it to make confetti and
they're gonna have what kind of parties
do you have there at the trump
organization i don't i don't know they
just say oh we're gonna keep winning and
so then there's so eric go go shred some
paper and then they make some confetti
and they said oh you can't i can't go to
the party store and they're like no you
gotta shred it to make some confetti and
then i'm like oh i will can i have some
money and then they're like we don't
have any money
so you're out of money you don't have
any money left is that why you're making
copies do you have a copy machine where
you're printing money
or is or is just the whole trump
organization a a laundry mat
what about laundry do you know
laundering money it seems as if it seems
as if why would you put money in the
laundry well is that the same as when
you five like five dollars in the
laundry in your pants and then you're
like no no eric eric eric eric eric
eric
do do you consider yourself intelligent
what do you consider yourself
intelligent smart
intelligent means smart
yeah
you're you consider yourself smart
uh-huh what about your what about your
your older brother don do you think don
is intelligent intelligent again it
means smart
um
yeah
uh
am i under oath
no this
you're you're on a podcast you're not
under oath but you are live can i play
the fifth
the fifth
do you know what the fifth is
um
it's the first amendment
not plus two second amendments
it that is
one plus two plus two is is five but
that that that's not the exactly what
the fifth amendment said two
two
rights to bear arms eric eric stay with
me stay stay with me stay with me or
stay with me here did you ever talk to
ivanka or don jr about laundering money
no
yes you didn't yeah no
no no you i don't i there's not a
specific answer that i want you to give
i want you to tell me the truth that's
all anyone's looking for that's what
okay
there was one time when they were like
hey eric uh we need you to go
throw some stuff in the laundry
i didn't know what they meant
right is this like a confetti room type
thing is this is there another room yeah
well i took it i took a bag i took bags
of stuff
and then i took it to these people yeah
and then they said
we've got it from here and i don't know
who
we got we got it from here so what did
they look like did they do they uh
did they appear to be russian
no
you're making me laugh and i don't know
if i should laugh or cry oh well well i
i would say i would say if um if
if this ends up the way that it seems
like it's gonna end up you're definitely
gonna be crying is that what you're
scared of are you scared to go to prison
are you scared to go to prison
have you ever considered that you might
go to prison
no
my dad said
yeah he said
he talked to you your dad actually
talked to you well like last year he
told me he said he said
don't worry about it
and i don't know what's
i don't know what to worry about
legitimate james is coming after me
why did you go why did you go on sean
hannity's show and make a fool of
yourself
i didn't make a fool of myself i was
there
i was there to defend myself and defend
defend the unfair treatment
that my family has been receiving
oh so so you believe you believe just
like last night on sean hannity so what
you're saying here is that you're being
treated unfairly because you committed
crimes and they're being investigated
possibly
yeah they're like coming after us
because they hate us they hate you or
because you committed crime
what crime
do you know what do you know what the
word crime means
um are you
is that like kremlin
no no no no no
i mean it can be it can't have to do
with russia but not everything has to do
with russia do you think everything has
to do with russia
well the democrats keep making and
hillary you know hillary's gonna turn
america in
into
this uh she she wants russia
um what what does she want about russia
like russian dressing on her salad or
or like what do you mean you know that
putin hates hillary that's why
putin really worked hard to support your
dad in 2016 and 2020.
what yeah putin loves your dad your dad
actually loves putin probably more than
putin loves him it's kind of like the
situation that you're in right you love
you love your dad way more than he loves
you your dad i love my daddy you love
you
i love my daddy
you you love your dad
do you think what is so funny do you
think your daddy loves don your brother
don
i don't know sometimes he calls him oh
hey what's your face what's your name
hey other one
the other powder knows he he says hey
hey hey hey blizzard face
hey
hey
hey hey hey kid who looks like casper
i i don't know
he just says his names
so he doesn't ever say don
what about booger sugar junior i like to
call your brother booger sugar junior
does he ever say that
i'm just seeing if my my uh my nicknames
are leaking through what about sugar no
no no no never mind never mind what
about your sister ivanka did she have to
do does she know about the crimes that
the trump organization has committed
here oh
ivanka is pretty
ivanka no no no i i i get that she's
like my she's like my wife laura
smokin
[Laughter]
right but i don't know why you're
laughing i
right i i get i get that you think your
your sister and your wife are pretty i
mean are they not pretty
they're fair enough
fair enough i'll give you that what i'm
asking though what i'm asking though is
did your sister have anything to do with
with the criming stuff with committing
crime
um
um
um can i plead the fifth again
no well i mean you you can you don't
have to answer the question but this is
you're not under oath you're not under
oath here
yeah she she did some crimes
oh
okay she did so this is not one or else
you said yeah right but it's not you're
not under oath so what kind of what kind
of my friend yeah before i came here
absolutely no you're my friend yeah
absolutely if you're gonna talk here
we'll let you talk here what
what what kind of crimes did she commit
oh well um
she and
don't tell anybody okay i won't tell
nobody promise cross my heart and hope
to die
she
she and jared um
they uh
yeah they did some um
they had some relations with foreign
entities
aunties and entities
and
right
i get it i get it i get it
go to your next thought if you have one
they made these deals um
where they went into these back rooms
and then they were like using private
messaging servers and stuff
and then i would be like
daddy what's going on please daddy
please and then and then
she was like
no don't rap me out and then and then i
was like i'm not i'm just trying to make
sure that no one gets in trouble
so so she was scared that you would rat
her out in a deposition do you know what
a deposition is
i'm not depressed no no no not
depression deposition where you go
before prosecutors and you
tell them what happened i was there i i
said i um i played the fifth like
i don't know like is that why you just
say plead the fifth all the time is
because you're so used to saying it when
someone asks you
a question
well i was i was instructed that i
should say i played the fifth who who
were you instructed by
um
what's what's their name do you know the
name of the person
it's okay you can say it here you're
you're on live but you're not under oath
remember you can say anything you want
my dad your your dad
she said it so you did actually talk to
you he talked to you yeah this was last
this was 2020 when i did this deposition
yeah and i was like super sad and i was
like daddy please help me daddy please
and then he said
don't say word please the fifth and i
was like
what and he's like
don't say a [ __ ] word lead the fifth
and i was like
okay daddy
and then leticia james was super mean to
me in that room
they don't even give you juice
what kind of juice did you want apple
juice oh is that your favorite juice
eric is that your
apple juice do you like animal crackers
is it
i love animal crackers you do
yeah
do you ever do you ever have animal you
ever dip the animal crackers in the
apple juice i've never no
no i've never i i don't you gotta try
man it's so good it really yeah is that
so that's what you're upset about that
tits james didn't give you apple juice
and animal crackers is that the well she
was really she was really mean she was
making all these accusations you accu
she was accusing you of stuff right yeah
she was accusing me of stuff yeah and
she was accusing my family right
all these things what she's like things
you guys improperly valued your company
what is what does that mean exactly do
you remember doing that
i i don't know i told you i just deliver
coffee and i make confetti sure i sign
autographs for people but i don't know
what's going on you don't know what's
going on at the trump organization you
just make confetti in the shredding room
and you deliver coffee what's in the
coffee there by the way is it decent
coffee or is it shitty coffee i is it
cheap i just mean eat the coffee grounds
you eat the coffee grounds no you're not
supposed to eat the coffee ground
through the coffee grounds and you pour
hot water in your mouth it's no no no no
no no no that's how you make that's how
you make coffee you nasty
okay let's get back on track here let's
get back on track you keep getting me
off track with the coffee grounds the
animal crackers and the apple juice
you're asking the questions yeah well
you're like leticia james i didn't get
the answer that i wanted tell me the
answers answer my questions answer my
questions
your dad did this your sister did this
you did this i don't know what's going
on guys okay it's like jeez give me a
second to breathe
so what was she accusing your sister of
doing ivan you're talking about ivanka
right not tiffany because you have you
have two sisters ivanka and tiffany
which which sister was she accusing
who's tiffany
you have a sister a half-sister named
tiffany
tiffany trump
never heard of her never heard of her
oh okay well so your sister ivanka jesus
christ your sister ivanka um
what what uh what was tish james
accusing her of
um
she was
she's she said that as one of the head
people of the organization that she was
the person that was behind it they said
that she might have been
the the mastermind
do you think your sister ivanka is a
mastermind i know you think she's pretty
but do you think she's a mastermind
i mean
i i don't know i don't know i mean like
don says that he's the powerful one and
then
and then sometimes
baron says that we're all idiots
and then you know
ivanka says she says sometimes
i'm gonna own this place someday and
it's like what does that even mean like
well i even have a job where do i live
how do i afford my penthouse and she
goes
don't worry about it and it's like i
don't know why these people are no
peanut butter
and like just always be nice to me
[Music]
so
so here eric get it together get it
together
get it together would you please would
you please we're we're running out of
time here we got 10 minutes until the
top of the hour so yeah
i got 10 more minutes to to talk to you
so do you want to respond to the uh
what you said last night on the hannity
show you know a lot of people on twitter
are really raking you through the coals
here they're calling you you know whiny
little [ __ ] and stuff is there anything
you'd like to tell the people out there
on twitter of
[Music]
i went on this show last night and i was
proving myself and i wanted to prove to
my father and my family that i am a real
man
so so you think you're a real man is it
is that why you went on sean hannity's
yeah it's like
okay cool i'm a real boy but like i'm a
real man who who doesn't think you're a
real man in your family my wife your
wife doesn't laura's like always like oh
why don't you just do more why don't you
grow up and you roll a pair of balls you
know i put some pants on i wanted to be
a real person and defend yourself well
you letting your cocoa brother just put
you around and your egotistical sister
just stop you like your little baby
[Laughter]
it's like i am a real person okay right
it's like at least i didn't steal money
from a puppy organization you know
so so i seen a video on time speaking of
your wife
um she makes a lot of videos but there
was a video
of you and her on social media while
back i don't know if it went on the
instagram or what but um she was doing
her makeup and you're holding the
brushes you seem to really know what
makeup brushes are which
do you do that a lot do you know
yeah all the time when i was a kid my
sister ivanka would say okay time to
play dress-up doll and then we'd go into
the room and then she was like okay
brush brush brush here's the foundation
here's the powder here's the mascara
here's the lipstick here's the eyeliner
oh we're gonna crimp your eyelashes
we're gonna tweeze your eyebrows we're
gonna we're gonna put some filler on
your
lips she was said it was great you know
she was like i'm gonna i'm gonna run
this place someday and i need to know
exactly what i need to do and she's like
this is how you're gonna look and you're
my little person i'm gonna push you
around and it was fun for a while so
it's not fun anymore for her to push you
around is that what you're saying no
it's not she's fun it's not fun to do
that is she still pushing around ivanka
or your wife
do they push you around
they're both hot but right i i know i i
know how you feel about how they look i
get that we we went over that already
sure they pushed me around but like
it's like i'm kind of like into it now i
don't even know
no it's like sometimes they push me
around i'm like oh that hurts and other
times i'm like
ow that hurts
and then and then and then they say oh
say daddy please and i'm like okay daddy
please and then we all smile and laugh
and it's amazing
they they like to say oh daddy please is
that what you're yeah and you're not
under oath so you can say just about
anything you want here
on the show so um but what you're saying
is is that ivanka and your wife say oh
daddy please is that is that what i'm
hearing yeah
yeah okay well
i appreciate you
sometimes don will say oh i'll hear him
on the phone sometimes when i go over to
visit him like you know when we're like
talking about what we should say to
people and i mean uh what i mean um
anyway um you mean you need to get like
your story straight or
yeah he says like okay remember those
times we'd go camping and then like dad
would never show up so then we'd have to
make stories about what we were doing
that weekend with dad you know and and
then and then we would go back to school
and we say guys this weekend we hung out
with our dad he took us camping and we
made a fire and we made marshmallows and
s'mores and we cooked over the fire
so we had to make stories up and now
don and i meet up you know and
we talk about
what we need to tell people what do you
know he said it's just like those
campfire stories what do you mean you
need to tell people you mean like you
need to tell stories tell lies to people
because you're trying to hide something
or what what
don don said we're not lying we're
helping
he said he said we're not lying he goes
we're not lying
and then sometimes he goes joe biden and
i just like
don't understand it because he's like we
have to make sure he's like we have to
make sure that joe biden gets out of
office and then i'm like what does this
even have to do with anything and then
he's like joe biden is all it's all
attached and then i'm like okay and so
then he's like we have to get our story
straight so that you know when people
come after us we aren't going to go down
so
so you like the way he says joe biden
because i kind of like the way he says
joe biden isn't it
yeah he's like it's like joe biden
it's it's it's it's a lot of fun to say
it's a lot of fun here's the thing i
don't really have a problem with joe
biden you know oh really you like it you
like joe you like joe joe's cool joe's
cool but my my brother hates him and my
dad really hates him
why do you think your your brother hates
him
probably because
don told me one time that he secretly
has a crush on
hunter biden
a crush what do you mean a crush he was
like oh man
hunter biden gets actual love from his
father
not like us
oh so he's jealous of hunter biden
that's why he doesn't like joe cause joe
loves hunter is that
yeah it's like sure hunter screwed up
we're all screwed up you know like look
at my father he was never there with us
on camping trips but like here we are
making up stories about how he was there
on camping trips and we have to just
cope into ways that we don't even know
and there's probably years of of
emotional damage that has put distress
on us and now here we are and hunter has
screwed up just like all of us but the
only difference between hunter biden and
joe biden and don jr and me and and
ivanka and that other person you said
tiffany i think and with with our father
trump the only difference is that
joe biden actually
loves his
son
yeah well i mean you know most fathers
do most fathers do love their sons
that's the thing that happens a lot even
if they're kind
our dad
doesn't like to
be emotional
and i'm an emotional guy i i can tell i
can tell so so let's get back to your
dad and joe biden why why doesn't your
joke why did your dad like like joe
biden that much what's what what is it
because
he thinks that
he's he's like oh no look he's like oh
no look this guy is a better president
than me and i'm like dad it's like
what's going on what are you talking
about you were a great president you
made america great again and then you
made america great again again and he's
like doesn't matter doesn't matter joe
biden joe biden's the worst thing that
ever happened to this country he's a
cancer he can't even get words out
and then i'm like but but dad you also
have trouble getting words out
it takes you two hands to drink a glass
of water now he's like don't talk to me
so he does the uh thing that huh yeah
yeah
yeah you know you do you do it you do a
good impersonation of your your brother
dawn and your dad can you do ivanka
because you did you did laura and you
did ivanka
you do a pretty good impress
impersonation um
sure okay
okay um yeah go ahead
just put the makeup on [ __ ]
that is that is that ivanka or is that
your wife laura
that was ivanka oh okay can you do your
wife laura did you do that one sure
just put the makeup on [ __ ]
eric i i really do appreciate you coming
on and um you know giving us all this
information i'm sure it'll be very
valuable to prosecutors um that are
looking into you your father and your
family business wait wait no you said
you said this wasn't on the record yeah
i was having a lot of fun i thought we
were gonna be my friend
well we're live the problem is is i
can't un-publish it it's already out
there in on the interwebs do you know
what the interwebs are
you know what social media is do you
know how to do that type of thing um
no
um
no um
i just
um
one time i was on the internet and i
watched this video and it said put the
lotion on the skin and i was like what
is this and then my
my sister was like get away from there
so your sister does the
thing too
yeah everyone in the family just goes
that's what that's what they do to you
yeah there i was just watching this
video and it was like put the lotion on
the skin and i was like what is this and
she was like
it's like i was just watching a video on
youtube
what's wrong i was just trying to watch
a video
well eric
is there anything else you'd like to
tell the audience or tell the world
before we have to
before you do you have to go soon are
you
i mean like i gotta go pee in a second
oh okay
that must be all the apple juice huh
yeah do you know that apple juice and
pee are the same color
yeah i i know they're they're very
because this one time when i was a kid
my brother and my sister did this joke
this practical joke they said and it was
like they're like hey eric how would you
try this warm apple juice this is worm
apple juice
and it was like what are you guys
talking about and then and then i was
like okay fine and then i drank it of
course because it was like it was warm
and it it's they said it was apple juice
and then
and it wasn't
okay it wasn't
what was it what was it do you think do
you think it was something that looked
like apple juice
i don't know they kept laughing at me
and they were like oh and they said it
was p but i don't believe them they
wouldn't do that but then i find out
later that i find out my dad's also into
pee and that was crazy oh really so tell
us tell us about i know you have to go
soon but tell us please tell us about
how your dad
was crazy
he was like i'm gonna go to russia and
i'm gonna talk to putin myself so he
went to russia and then i was like oh my
god
well can you bring me back some trinkets
and then he came back and then it turns
out that there was this tape that was
made and it was like it wasn't me it
wasn't me and i was like dad what are
you doing and then and then he was like
this tape on the internet it's not me
it's not me there's some trinkles
there's some showers it's golden and
then i was like
what and then he was like if you hear
anything it wasn't me fake news
and so then
people have said my dad's in a pee and
that he took
uh
this thing with pee and a bed and with
these
russian models
people are saying that people are people
been saying that for a long time i think
i think james comey actually uh briefed
your dad
um
when
i think he briefed him
when he was becoming president do you
remember that trump tower he actually
came and he briefed your dad on the um
yeah my dad picked him out of the office
again why did he
go make some confetti go get some coffee
oh really so you became confetti coffee
boy at that point when um yeah and
here's the thing spoiler that's where
kofi comes from oh really so kofi is
coffee confetti is that the mm-hmm
okay well
breaking news i appreciate it yeah i've
been wondering here i am under wraps
can't talk about it well here you go
folks okay
go fave that's what it's from
that's fantastic i'm glad you cleared
that up for us because the world was
wondering exactly what a lot of people
on twitter these days i read the tweets
that come at me everyone's always like
your dad said go fave your dad said go
fave well here's the thing he meant it
he put it there on purpose okay because
he is a genius
oh
eric
you're killing me man you're killing me
um
how much longer do you have to hang out
and i could probably hold my bladder for
like a few more minutes a few more it's
okay so so the apple the apple juice is
not uh is not an urgent then nature is
not calling urgency
if i really need to i'll just do it
right here
oh okay so so do you what because it's
like super super warm you know and it
feels good it feels really good and
you're like oh yeah because like
sometimes when we go camping you know
without my dad and my and i was there
with my brother you know it'd be like oh
no the fire went out how do we stay warm
and then
the guy that was watching us was like
just be your pants
the guy that was watching you what what
what do you mean the guy that was
watching you
i don't know he was just like some
employee
some employee huh took you guys camping
is that is that the story that you told
that who was your dad did you pretend he
was your dad when when he was there
yeah yeah i did i mean it was like i had
to say it was my dad you know and my dad
was able to do this and do that and i
had to i had to make up stories because
when the kids when you come back to
school you never be like what'd you do
this weekend and i said we went camping
with my dad and people like what are you
talking about i saw him on fifth avenue
and i was like
no you didn't and then i would have to
make up some lie about how we made a
fire and and made s'mores and cooked
food and caught fish
and
were were men of the land
oh so so so you make up these stories
that you're that you're manly
is that why don junior wears flannel now
i noticed that in the last few years
your brother don jr has switched to
flannel he went from you know your fake
cheap ass
suits to uh flannel he's got the al
borland look i mean you're kind of doing
it too you got the beard going you know
you got the old uh 1990s out borland
look going but
is that why you switched to flannel
shirts
no that's because he has sensitive
nipples
his what he has sensitive nipples the
shirts
that we make from trump are very rough
okay are they the trump shirts that are
made in china that come over here very
rough on the skin and they were causing
irritations he actually had an allergic
reaction and it caused his nipples to
chafe so now he has to use flannel
because it's much softer so he goes and
buys a ll bean from jcpenney
so you know you know that you can
you can wear an undershirt underneath
your shirt so you don't chafe the nip
never mind um no because my dad said
you gotta touch the skin
you gotta touch it you put the lotion on
the skin and you put the shirt to the
skin
trump to trump touch it
okay so that's what he said
so he doesn't want you to use
undershirts i i get that so let me get
back to uh don jr and flannel shirts
because i find it i find it amusing when
he does these videos on instagram have
you ever seen your brother's videos on
this instagram
no
you've never seen don junior's videos on
instagram where he's he's looking down
at note cards and he's talking into the
camera and he says weird things i've
seen the ones on facebook oh is it
facebook okay facebook instagram
whatever the hell it is but you've seen
these videos that he does uh-huh yeah
what do you think about the videos that
your brother does
have you ever considered doing these
videos i'm usually in the room and i'm
the one directing and i'm like
okay
eyes up
open eyes open
open your eyes
so
i'm there i'm like i'm like a real
hollywood director
so what else do you tell him when you're
directing
do you direct him to to not snort as
much coke beforehand or does he try to
do as
much drugs before he presses record
i've never seen him do any drugs i just
show up and he's got he's like i got all
these like he's like i got all these
ideas about joe biden about ukraine all
this stuff and so then i go there and
he's already like it's like he's had
like 10 cups of coffee you know and so
then you think it's so you think it's
the coffee that's that's got him all
jacked up
maybe maybe he's shredding documents and
having coffee i don't even know but what
i will say is whenever i go over there
to direct him to make these little home
videos he is already going he's like a
million miles a minute and then i have
to catch up so i'm chewing coffee beans
and i'm pouring hot water in my mouth
and i'm making mouth coffee
and then he starts filming and then i go
okay okay quick ready look up look up
smile smile wipe the tears from your
eyes okay and
action
and then he and then he's like joe biden
and i'm like perfect and then after that
you know he he he does uh
between takes you know he's got to blow
his nose a lot you know he'd sometimes
get bloody noses which is kind of gross
but he says it's because the altitude
so the altitude where in florida the
altitude in florida gives him bloody
noses is it
he said it's like sub-level altitude i
don't know listen i'm not a scientist
okay but what i will say is i help them
make those videos and i think that they
could win an oscar
so so you consider yourself a filmmaker
because you showed up while don junior's
doing his selfie videos for facebook is
it
yeah what i mean i i even i even write
the note cards for him i write it to you
is that the ones he's looking at because
he can't remember yeah he can't remember
to say joe biden
yeah and those those cards are just
one
word per card so it's like
joe
biden
you know like is that why so so is that
why he says it like that
he's is that why he says it like that
yeah yeah
because i i was like
bye then that's what i do on the cards
okay so so do you add in letters on the
cards so you'll draw it out like that
yeah okay yeah i do um um
um what i like to call
phonetical
spelling
fun magical
fun because it's fun or because it's fun
i mean that's what my tutor taught me um
i mean
we still kind of go on a daily basis
about it but
um i'll see you guys
you're still being tutored
uh-huh
yeah okay well that makes sense that
makes sense
and eric
did you piss your pants or you need to
go to the bathroom what's the
i just checked i didn't
you didn't okay no but i i i do need to
go um because uh i need to talk with don
about like you know
campfire stories
campfire stories yeah that's what we
call it when we need to um figure out
what we need to say to people
okay well i'll let you and don
work on your campfire stories i really
appreciate you joining us uh come back
anytime seriously you are welcome here
to um
uh to say whatever you would like on air
um
so everyone can hear your voice because
you know you have the first amendment
which is the freedom of speech you know
that's the first one right right and
then if i if i put two second amendments
yeah i'm gonna get right
yes yes we know we don't think thank you
eric for joining us thank you um
audience stay with us we'll
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
oh holy [ __ ]
[Music]
well
you heard it right here on let's talk to
tony michael's podcast
he had